[Music]
sometimes you watch a Disney movie and
you feel like you've seen this before
and it's not because we watched it five
times in a row when you were seven years
old Disney animators really recycle to
old scenes into a new movie and if you
want to see the popular character who is
recycled the most times you'll have to
watch our video until the end if you
love Disney as much as we do don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up
today we're showing you ten times Disney
recycled animation in its movies Snow
White and the Seven Dwarfs it all
started with the first full-length
animated feature film and the first
Disney Princess Snow White this one
didn't copy any other animated movies
but the animators did recycle some
footage of a woman dancing to create the
beautiful character marge champion with
the actress who played Snow White in
real life she was only 14 years old just
like the princess when she auditioned
for Disney animators and they
immediately fell in love with her as she
had the elegance and the graceful motion
of the princess being raised by her
father who is a dance choreographer they
first asked her to wear a football
helmet to create a character with a
bigger head but it was terrible to work
with that then there was no choreography
and they just asked Marge to dance and
do whatever she wanted with her friends
the dwarfs she even played characters
like dopey when they put a big coat on
her and asked the actors to do funny
things the animators filmed her and use
these videos to draw Snow White and the
Seven Dwarfs at first no one talked
about marge champion because Disney
didn't know how people would react but
he found out that people didn't really
care so this secret was finally revealed
we think that knowing about March just
makes this story more fascinating hey
guys we are so excited to announce we
are producing our own original content
head over to the trendy for the best
DIYs fashion tips makeup acts and so
much more we are sure you're going to
love it
and be sure to let us know what you
think in the comment section we love to
hear from you
robin hood when she danced for the
animators large champion didn't know
that she would be part of another movie
and that's not because they hired her
one more time to dance for them they
just used a scene from Snow White in the
Seven Dwarfs
for their new movie Robin Hood's take a
look at the day of scenes with Snow
White and the Seven Dwarfs
and Maid Marion and her little friends
both ladies started clapping and have
fun with their group of friends to the
sounds of music
don't you think that this is really
similar lots because this is exactly the
same scene but with different characters
and since the war Disney often recycled
his old movies to create new ones this
is called rotoscoping the animators draw
and trace over old footage to create
something new so March champion was the
inspiration for Snow White who is the
inspiration for Maid Marion we know that
some stories look really similar
justtake Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs
and we've been Beauty for example but we
never thought that could go so far and
it's crazy to think that we didn't even
see it but wait until you see all the
other scenes that were recycled in other
movies and we'll also tell you why they
did that if you keep watching the
aristocrats Robin Hood is not only
inspired by Snow White in the Seven
Dwarves but also by many other movies
one of them is their Vista Kratts this
is another dance scene that looks
exactly the same but with different
characters they didn't even change the
instruments that they play and it's
crazy to think that there is two cats
also copy the scene from 101 Dalmatians
when an animal is terrified as someone
was walking towards them they just
changed everything around to make it
look different but fans knew that they
remembered the scene but why were the
animators doing that actually the thing
is at that time people didn't watch
these movies as much as we do they may
be watched at one - the movie theater
and they forgot about it and even when
people started listening to the V
test they didn't binge watch the movies
as we all do now Disney just never
thought that we would one day have
access to all these creations and that
we would start comparing them it just
became worse when we have access to the
Internet and started talking about it
and sharing our thoughts on this
surprising recycling this is how we
discovered that so many scenes were so
similar but did the animators want to
save money or were they just too lazy
let's ask them to find out the Jungle
Book
here's another movie that inspired Robin
Hood one of the dance scenes with the
Bears and their friends was exactly the
same they even made the same silly faces
and we saw an elephants doing the same
thing at the end Robin Hood is not
really surprising after all if you
watched the previous busy movies you
already knew what was coming next but
that's not the only time the Jungle Book
was used as an inspiration as you could
also see a scene that was really similar
in the rescuers but now we had been
wondering if the animators wanted to
save money or if they were just lazy
don't worry they're not lazy at all as
it takes a lot of time to work on such a
beautiful movie and they have to deal
with really strict deadlines if you
can't do this job you can't judge them
but most people think that it was just
about money after all people would think
that just recycling the same scene saves
a lot of them so they don't have to pay
the animators for all this work and as
Disney was losing money at the time it
would totally make sense but someone who
works for Disney told us the truth about
this and it's probably far from what you
think Beauty and the Beast
we'd love watching Disney Princess
movies so much that we can't believe
that we haven't seen this one before you
the bees copy the scene from Sleeping
Beauty and once again it was a dancing
when the princesses were dancing with
their prince by the end of the movie
their choreography was exactly the same
we know that there are not a lot of
moves they could do with this kind of
dance but they probably took things a
little too far but they actually had a
good reason to do that and it might
surprise you so stay tuned
Floyd Norman works on a lot of Disney
movies and he says that it was not about
saving time or money after all
he thinks that it's actually harder and
longer to draw an existing sequence the
animators had to find the perfect scene
find the original drawings and all this
took a lot of time actually there's a
lot faster and easier to do just a new
animation and it was a lot more fun for
the animators after all copying
something is what we do in detention not
in art class and animators wanted to
give life to their unique characters
this is why Floyd will have to tell us
soon the real reason why they recycled
these scenes the sword in the stone
this movie is probably the one that had
the most recycled teams it was even
worse than Robin Hood's can you guess
how many scenes from previous movies
they recycled there were actually 10 one
of them was from Bandys which we will
talk about later another one was from
Goliath too but most people didn't see
that movie so it didn't really matter
then there was another scene with a big
rock from all in a nutshell the sea
monster from Sea Scouts and the
character from Tiger trouble reimagined
as a weird creature we can also see a
whole scene with Knights coming straight
from another movie the truth about
Mother Goose there is no way Disney fans
won't be able to notice the similarities
between these two we also noticed that
some scenes from The Adventures of
Ichabod and mr. toad and Pinocchio were
really similar and we can't believe that
they even recycled a scene from Sleeping
Beauty and we didn't see that and we're
not even done yet you've probably never
heard about the sword in the stone
because this movie was not really
popular this is the proof that sometimes
recycling too many scenes is not really
a good idea but that doesn't mean that
it wouldn't work in other movies 101
Dalmatians and just when we thought that
the sword in the stone couldn't copy
more movies we found out that we were
wrong there was one last scene that we
didn't talk about from 101 Dalmatians
they made exactly the same joke twice
and we can't believe that we laughed
once again but that's not the only time
that this movie was used as an
inspiration the Jungle Book copied many
scenes including one from 101 Dalmatians
and don't forget the aristocrats that we
talked about sooner but now it's time to
finally know why they are taking the
time to do all this we all know that
Disney likes to take a lot of risks with
his movies after all he was the first to
create a full-length animated feature
film and captivate children from all
over the world he is now still known for
all his innovations but sometimes it's
easier to simply do the same thing the
animators like to play it safe and use
stuff that they know would work we loved
watching this scene the first time so we
would love to watch it once again and
since we love to watch most of the
movies on this list we can say that it
worked we can't believe that they
tricked us and we didn't even see it
Alice in Wonderland can you believe that
there is one last scene that Robin Hood
recycled from another movie it's when
Alice was running away in the castle you
will notice that it's really similar to
what they did in the other movies years
after but Alice in Wonderland is also
guilty of recycling some scenes from
other movies isn't it strange that the
birds playing in the water did exactly
the same thing in Bambi and Alice in
Wonderland we also noticed that fish
like to do exactly the same thing in
Pinocchio and
the new movie at least the animators
made some efforts to create something
new once again they hired an actress to
play the lead role and this young girl
wasn't only dancing she also played the
scenes but it must have been really hard
for her to do that as she had to imagine
all the things surrounding her the
animators filmed her and this is how
they were able to recreate a character
that looks exactly the same this is what
they called live-action reference now we
understand why this character looks so
real
catherine beaumont said that play the
role of Alice was one of the highlights
of her career no one really saw her but
we could still hear her because she was
also the voice of the character this is
how we will remember her forever
Bambi one of the scenes from this movie
was so beautiful that it wasn't only
used in one movie but in many other
movies through guess how many they were
actually for we all remember when the
animals were living peacefully in the
forest it looks so great that Disney
wanted to make sure that we would see
this image again and again this is why
we saw something similar in the sword in
the stone The Jungle Book the rescuers
and Beauty and the Beast and just
because you can never get enough of
Bambi another animal was seen in two
other movies the new neighbor and the
rescuers do you want to see more fun and
fancy-free
also recycled some animation from the
movie and don't forget the scene with
the birds and Alice in Wonderland it was
a big challenge for the animators to
work with animals as they wanted to make
it look real and this time they use
live-action references - at first
animals were brought to studio art
classes for close-up studies by the
Disney artists we would have loved to be
there on that day
then it lives behind the studio so the
animators could always have access to
real-life inspiration so if you want to
work with animals you have to be an
animator on a movie like Bambi we need
the Pooh and here comes the popular
movie which use the most references from
other movies actually this time they
didn't recycle animation from other
movies kept from Winnie the Pooh itself
that's right winnie-the-pooh copied
winnie-the-pooh so if you watch this
bear a little too much you will notice
that some things are really similar for
example one scene from Winnie the Pooh
and the honey tree is almost exactly the
same as another scene from Winnie the
Pooh and the blustery day if you think
that things have gone too far
you'll be surprised then a whole scene
from Winnie the Pooh and the blustery
day was used in Winnie the Pooh and
Tigger too and that's not even the only
thing they recycled Winnie the Pooh and
the honey tree used 101 Dalmatians as an
inspiration then Winnie the Pooh and the
blustery day used one image from The
Adventures of Ichabod and mr. toad we
also saw the boy walked it exactly as
another boy did in the jungle book and
the Mini Adventures of Winnie the Pooh
and this is probably why the scene looks
so weird anyway we think that they took
this way so far and it needs to stop if
there is one scene from a Disney movie
that you could have the chance to see
once again what would it be don't be shy
to answer in the comment section down
below we'd love to hear what you think
and that's it for 10 times Disney
recycled animation and it's movies for
more stories like this make sure you
watch 10 worst straight-to-dvd Disney
sequels thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]